if I asked all of you to tell me the
first thing that comes to mind when I
say the word play there would probably
be as many answer
there are people in this audience for a
topic that seems so familiar and
universal it's oddly elusive and hard to
nail down in words to summit make a note
running around outside in the Sun a
childhood memory a favorite game toy or
gadget the varieties of play are vast
and unique to age and culture in today's
high-tech world the proliferation of
wireless devices alternate reality games
and social media have only further
broadened the landscape of play
tonight's talk is part of a larger
series called designing play which began
in February and invites people of all
ages to invent explore tinker adventure
and have fun over the past few months
we've relied on designers of all types
graphic landscape and architectural a
trained ones to create hands-on
opportunities for our visitors to play
and problem-solve the result unbridled
creativity and innovation that's given
rise to structures built from toothpicks
and gumdrops portraits construed from
various styles of typeface and landscape
drawings that allow the imagination to
run wild I've been very excited for this
evenings talk which is the culminating
moment of the series tonight's guests
Edith Ackerman is what I might call a
play expert trained as a developmental
psychologist she received her doctor of
developmental psychology two master's
degrees in developmental and clinical
psychology and a Bachelor of
Experimental Psychology all from the
University of Geneva Switzerland and is
currently a visiting scientist at the
Massachusetts Institute of Technology
School of Architecture her research has
led her to letter to team up with
partners such as MIT Media Lab the LEGO
Learning Institute and the Exploratorium
Museum in San Francisco to help shape
the future of play and learning in a
digital world
she comes from a lineage of thinkers and
scientists who have transformed the
fields of child development and
education including Jean Piaget who she
worked who she studied and collaborated
with Maria Montessori leva got ski and
Seymour pepper all of whom suddenly or
all of whom strongly believed that
learners construct knowledge through
Play Ackerman explains the overall
purpose of her work as threefold to
bring users back into the design process
to imagine and design
activities artifacts and spaces that
bring about delight and foster personal
and societal growth and to help
innovative teams of researchers and
practitioners bring strategic research
design and a user centered design
approach to product development I'd like
to quote Edith who says there are two
lessons that she has learned through her
career and research when it comes to
learning and creative uses of
technologies children have more to teach
adults than adults to children when it
comes to innovating for others don't
guess what they want or do what they say
co-create what they and you will love
once it is there I'd like to welcome
eateth Ackerman Thank You Ashley and
thank you for having me come to the
Walker Arts Center I am coming more from
the sciences and I am moving towards the
Arts so it's a great pleasure for me to
be able to talk here at the Walker Art
Center the title of my talk is playful
inventions and explorations which I
borrow actually from an title of
Institute and the network that exists
and that grew out of work that had been
done at the MIT Media Lab to begin with
in the group that was led by Mitchel
Resnick similar Peppard and other people
intended it grew across the country and
it included educators researchers
artists you know practitioners
theoreticians and the purpose was
actually to engage children in
activities that are innovative that are
playful and and and and there is a whole
evolution of this work that is happening
also here in Minneapolis in this Science
Museum and at the Exploratorium where I
had the chance to work quite a bit so
this evening I would like to talk a
little bit about these relationships
between play imagination creativity
innovation and design as Ashley said
there are as many definitions of of play
than people in this room and it has been
very difficult for me actually to
prepare this talk because each time when
you enter in the domain you you lose
yourself you get lost so it's just my
take on the question tonight and it
keeps changing and I just want to in a
way almost introduce a discussion so I
will talk about children's learning
children's play play and creativity in
children and grown-ups play for
education which is a difficult topic
it's like what could it be the future of
play in in so called in in today's
children so-called digital natives and
last but not least if I ever get there
is to think about places and
environments that can actually foster
the type of learning and play that I
want to talk about so let me start by
talking a little bit about the strong
beliefs and it's more than beliefs that
actually some of the lessons that I
learned in working especially with Jean
Piaget but then with other people also
on what what learning is about so the
idea is that children may not have
much experience or knowledge and I mean
experience in the sense of in German you
have these beautiful distinctions that
don't exist in other languages our own
means experiences when you are old and
wise and air lateness is experienced as
being totally mindfully into situations
so the children may not have much
experience in the sense of a theorem or
knowledge but they are sure born with a
knack to do the right thing in order to
get to know more about what they don't
know yet this is an important point in
and one way of talking about this is to
say that they are experts in
self-directed learning whatever that
means I like to think of a child that is
busy figuring out their place in the
world as a traveler or newcomer to a
foreign land that has to convey their
needs that has to that have to be heard
without really speaking the language
without knowing the habits that have to
plow along without knowing the terror
very well deciding when to move on and
when to settle deciding what to bring
along and what to leave behind and
decide who to trust and not to trust in
a way we have all had this experience
when we travel izing this is why people
like to travel because it's like
reenacting and experiencing these very
fundamental ways of handling uncertain
situations and the point here is that
what is very impressive with children is
that it's not just that they are very
good at languages we know that it's just
at the tip of the iceberg is that you're
incredible and we can learn a lot from
them in the way they maneuver and evolve
in a world that is by definition too
phlex uncertain and unpredictable for
them so that's a starting point and I do
like the the way in which John Piaget
who was my mentor and he is Swiss
developmental psychologist who is quite
well known he has had a strong influence
in education even if he didn't think of
himself as an educator and that that's
another interesting point he defined
intelligence as adaptation and what he
said is that to adapt is not just to
accommodate as we always think of it
it's not to change one's views or one's
ways of being or manners or even one's
look just to conform to once around like
a chameleon who uses a camouflage
technique of changing color to to
disappear in the in the back in the
background or the character of vague in
in in Woody Allen's film who always
takes on tries to please whoever is
around and tries to be loved and to
belong so strongly that he has no spinal
cord anymore he's he's like a chameleon
so if you think of the ways in which
people adapt to their world and
especially young people who who are
still very malleable because they have
still a lot to learn one important
aspect that sometimes gets
underestimated is is that you also have
to stay whole you have to withstand you
have to remain who you are you have to
keep your identity even if you are
constantly put into situations where you
know that require in a way that you
change your views and what is very
strong is this notion that to adapt is
not to control the uncontrollable or to
predict what is and predict
stable but it is in a way this notion
that you have to create an ease in which
it becomes possible to actually live and
evolve in ways that are pleasant and
agreeable to the person organism that we
are considering so the the whole theory
of of Keshe that I am very actually
influenced by is built around is this
notion of what it means to actually be
you know fulfilled personally and also
intellectually and in a way to succeed
succeed in the world so at the beginning
the children are very fused with their
world there is like no distinctions
between themselves in the world and as
they grow there is this bifurcation but
they always happen at the same time it's
like socialization individuation you
know becoming an agent and becoming in a
way able to relate to other people
attachment detachment and as they grow
older and I will not focus so much on
that the experiential field of a person
is is expanding they become able to not
just act in the here and now but they
draw lessons from the past to project
into the future and vice versa and also
the field the field as in the space is
expanding people feel people move about
as they grow older and expand their
field and they're they're they're
maneuvering techniques and their belief
systems become it's again a paradox more
stable and more mobile so what the
children we know it they are they are
learning everywhere and and all the time
you know and in school out of school and
and and they are learning through play
which the
adults to say grown-ups to say that
place to child's more serious work now
what I want to try to address is what
what does that mean you know what what
are the implications for anyone who is
interested in designing environments for
people for for young people to to
actually grow and and live in and and
learn in so I will talk a little bit
longer about champion and then I let a
let go of him he's mostly known for his
stages a developmental stages and in a
way it's important because it provides a
window in what young people are
interested in and able to do generally
at different levels or ages in their in
their development but there is more to
gather than his stages and the part
interest me most is this notion that
children have very coherent and robust
belief systems and that their belief
systems are stubborn they are not easy
easy to shake and that this is so for
very good adaptive reasons and the whole
theory shows that it's not to say that
the children don't change or are in not
influenced when they relate to other or
when they interact with the world
the views are constantly evolving but
they are evolving according to almost a
logic of their own the the when when
their beliefs system change its jump
wise so in other word what what this
means is that it's not just because you
experience something at some time that
you are going to learn these pieces of
knowledge is that you are
in the world in different ways and you
begin to form a very structured belief
system she calls it structure but it
doesn't matter it's like these pieces of
knowledge or ways of making sense of the
world
we hang together they have Co
dependencies between one another all
these to say that this has profound
implications for education
the first profound implication for
education of this view is that teaching
is always indirect no matter whether we
like it or not as educators teaching is
always indirect because people will
always interpret assimilate what we tell
them teach them show them the way we
guide them into situation according to
their own belief systems experiences
they will retranslated the the the more
disturbing and an important consequence
is that Joshi used to say it in a very
provocative way he said whatever you
teach to a learner you don't allow them
to discover by themselves it's this
notion of wait wait don't tell me when
kids wait wait don't tell me it's I want
to discover it by myself I mean I need
leads I need offerings but I want to
discover it by myself and related is
this notion that any theory of learning
that doesn't that ignores or doesn't pay
enough attention to resistances to
learning or teaching in a way misses the
point another important idea that was
developed more by people I work with
later in my life so I spent sort of half
of my life trying to understand how
children's worldviews evolve you know in
different domains like mostly in the
sciences at the time and then I started
working when I came to the US with
designers educators people who are
they try to design environments for
these kinds of learning to happen and
one of the important ideas also from
from the background and working with
pleasure and and the whole team is that
there are all these paradoxes if you
actually want children to internalize
their action or to become good thinker a
good way of doing it is to let them
externalize what they think because if
you project out or you if you build
something based on or if you reenact
something based on ideas that you have
you enter in a dialogue with your own
expressions and enactments and it allows
you to progress so it's it's again a
paradox and there are many examples I
don't have the time to go into it but if
you if you if you are really interested
in getting kids to get a sense of what
for example numbers are about or
understanding the concept of numeracy or
number three there are plenty of ways
that you can show embodiments of that
phenomenon in different contexts to
contextualize them differently but it's
never just one you see it's not like
we're gonna now talk about fractions and
we are gonna do the pie is that that
doesn't work you need a whole array of
possible embodiments of the concept and
it's it's the learner who makes the
connections between when they are ready
between these different contexts I now
want to try to talk more about play I
have I have spoken about learning to
long play
I like to think of play as the art of
world making and that play is about
inventing and invented realities is
about creating a world physical or
virtual inhabiting that world that world
and then eventually become inhabited by
it now sometimes you are invited into
invented realities that have been made
or designed by other people I thought I
liked to start with very silly examples
like the entertainment park look I think
this is the world where where the roller
coasters are and and imagine Humanity
has invented for itself these crazy
devices where people actually go there
to either take the driver's seat and
sort of experience the thrills of things
that if they did it in the real world it
would be really dangerous scary or be
taken for a ride even be taken for a
ride where you experience things in ways
that are just like not so usually in
real life and in a way I like to take
the example of the entertainment part
because we are all thinking that this is
not real play but in a way it is it is
very interesting to think about why
humanities has invented these kinds of
things the metaphor of the leap is a
leaping is often used I have an image
here of the leap to capture the sense of
exuberance and freedom that
characterizes children's play this time
P and I think it's a good metaphor
people leap when they feel like breaking
loose or shaking off their habitual ways
of doing things and of thinking they
they want to move out of their comfort
zone so we will leave
for example when we look at things from
different and surprising angles when we
zoom in and out of a situation as like
when you look at a drop of milk through
microscope or if you hover over a
stumble and then the South of France via
Google Earth when you actually sit in an
airplane and you see and you see the
landscape becoming smaller each time I
am I am amazed by this we leap when we
cross borders when we transgress when we
take a walk on the wild side of as Louie
was saying and in our minds we leap when
we mentally move between realms that
would otherwise be juxtaposed in our in
our every everyday experience that are
unlikely or when hooks stop posing these
world's words that are normally not
traversed you bring them together so
that's more mental way of thinking about
what leaping is examples is when you
move backwards and forward in time which
children always doing pretend play I am
the baby I am the Papa and Mama they
like the Russian dolls because you
spatial version of it almost the little
one goes in the big one and then you put
them in a row all these games it's
talking to our dolls to imaginary
companions
it's a displacement pretense that you
know that all the pretense play or
putting oneself in other people's shoes
it's like more more roleplay now one can
go a long way using that the metaphor of
the leap to think about play but I feel
and this is more personal add-on I think
that the metaphor of the leap is
important but what is equally important
to think about when we think about play
is the count what I call the comeback
it's a sense of sort of a settling
exhilaration that young children can see
that emerge through an acting in a way
the return so the reason why this is
important is that you cannot leap
without the landing or there is no
levity without gravity so as much as
kids love to move on you know imagine a
toddler you know that the thrills of all
of the sudden be able to to travel in
the world and and to have this whole
world sort of turning around and while
while when they move on they also like
to come back and the whole toy industry
for young children is built around this
notion that for example when a young
child moves about in the world and and
is disoriented there is a reason to have
a pool along toy with you because what
it does is that it gives you a sense
that there is something invariant there
is something constant it's your distance
from it it's the fact that it follows
you and it creates this sense almost of
a very ephemeral home for a little while
which which is important the children
play home one of our colleagues Diane
Diane willow actually just put a tent
inside of the Children's Museum with
light coming from from inside it's it's
a beautiful exhibit because it taps into
children's desire to have treehouses you
know their own little secret gardens and
so on and there is another thing that is
important it's the Hansel and Gretel our
aspect is like it's nice to wander into
the forest it's nice to go wait for the
moment of magic it's nice to go catch
the butterflies but it's also nice to
know that you
can come back and the whole mythology of
the labyrinth of leaving a thread behind
of leaving breadcrumbs behind is an
enactment of this desire to both move
out transgress walk on the white side
and have ways of coming back and as soon
as the children learn to actually talk
and scribble at the same time because
it's not that one appears before the
other it there again it's a be few
occasion when the children become like
two three years of age
they acquire what is called a symbolic
function and it is made of it has all
these manifestations learning to speak
playing with imaginary companion
starting to pretend make belief
suspension of disbelief first sense of
humor and an incredible excitement when
they can leave faces behind you know
when they when they write when they
write and when when they walk they
become interested in steps and I think
those are very fundamentals and they are
played out constantly when when the
children when the children are at play
and probably also and grown-ups are at
play this one okay I had collected quite
some few definitions of play but I am
going to let them go there is one that
is important is by Winnicott he talks
about the importance of transitional
zones and he talks about these objects
that very young children fall in love
with because in a way it allows them
again to navigate the unknown and it
case it's more relational it has to do
with the mother that is not always so
good because every now and then she
lives and and and and to keep in a way
this this transitional object is this
blanket or whatever the object
is a way of of actually saying I can
survive I can survive this this at this
separation and they treat the
transitional objects in the way that
they think they are treated by the
person who cares about them
so the Winnicott speaks beautifully
about the fact that the transitional
object has to be forgiving enough and
resilient enough to be loved but also
hated to be you know to be treated in
all kinds of ways and drawn halt is a is
an educator he says that you know when
children play and use fantasy it's not
to get out but to get into the world and
this is an important idea because when
we see for example kids playing video
games and so we spoke about this at
lunch it is it is it is not that it's an
escape it's like if I read the book it's
not an escape from reality it gives me
the possibility to actually establish a
dialogue between what is and what could
be it allows me to invent different
narratives than the ones that I am
experiencing under certain sets of
constraints by changing those sets of
constraints and embellishing or or the
opposite or or or just giving in a way
the kind of wait and ending that that
that are more feel more desirable
now the the play and creativity is
another difficult distinction to make
because it's not the same in children in
grown-ups and it's not necessarily the
same in the sciences and in the arts and
yet they have something in common many
people and Bobo know in particular they
talk about the fact that creative
individuals I have it here scientists
artists or just plain Fork
usually make better use of what is
called lateral thinking in a way
slightly ping an ability to break loose
from acquired mental habits by looking
at a problem from different angles doe
bono has been popularized in ways that
are not interesting but he himself was a
deep thinker and and what he said is
that lateral thinkers tend to explore
all the different ways of looking at
something rather than accepting this is
important the most promising and proof
proceeding from that they do not assume
that all the ideas should have
precedence until something better turns
up this is very cassia I mean as long as
my worldview are good enough I'm not
going to change so in a way it's its
dominance --is it's not that they are in
opposition but they are people and I I
noticed this with designers a lot who
are more willing to play that game of
not taking for granted what actually has
become things they know or believe in so
one way of thinking about this is to say
normally at least in in scientists the
idea is to - look - to - I have it
written here
it's driven more part by curiosity vibe
than playfulness and those seem a bit
artificial to separate but I think it's
a useful thing to do at least for a
little moment curiosity is driven by the
urge to figure out how things work to
grasp the logic of the patterns behind
the surface of things to explain things
away sometimes be too much to debug to
prove you know and they have a clear
adaptive function it's to turn
unfamiliar into the familiar the unknown
into the known playfulness is doing
something different it's sort of driven
by the desire to imagine alternatives
which actually scientists do a lot if
they are if they are innovative
suspension of disbelief is so important
the ability to fictionalize to dramatize
reality and it's adaptive function is
slightly different from the one of
getting to know it to turn the familiar
or the taken-for-granted
into the uncanny the humerus and the
incongruous I am going to pass on this
this is the notion that it's very
important to let the objects talk when
you are actually in the in the process
of playing and and and and also in a
design process and and children at play
or people who are playful do that a lot
they the relative objects talk for for
to help them know it I am sorry I am NOT
being clear on that there are there
there are people who are always able to
solve problems in ways that allows them
to think less and those are the real
smart ones and my favorite example is is
a Gaudi when he when he was building the
models for the Sagrada família
he realized that if he has some some
threads hanging and if he puts weights
on them and if you imagine you put this
in in a liquid that sort of you could
freeze them so to speak if you return
them you actually get the mathematics of
the of the of the arches in the other
direction and in working with children I
constantly fall upon children who are
good at that so if you if you are you
know asking a complicated problem like
there is this car driving around the
lake and there is this person sitting
driving is on the side of the lake when
the car is on the other side where we so
you have the kids are going they go like
this in this case it's not using the
object but your own body instead of of
looking at it from God's eyes view and
and and calculating the reverse or there
there are children we were playing a
game of exchanging equal volumes of wood
but they were cut in such a vicious way
that you had an equivalence between two
blocks against three so the question was
you know it's the property common
denominator of the smallest denominator
so the question is you know how many how
many bricks how many blocks does this
person have to give to this person so
that they have the same amount of wood
and you have these kids that just go
like they just start somewhere they
align the blocks until they align
themselves then it's like okay and then
you go in another direction until it
aligns itself and then guess what they
go in the third direction and then they
get that cube you know that that is
equal to the other one never they had
counted never they had made a
multiplication and I can multiply the
examples of working with young children
on on new on numbers where they are
incredible they are able to actually
reconstruct same quantities elsewhere
and it's not just perceptive they would
go like an
they are three and there are two and
there is one and there is five so they
use the ability to name small quantities
perceptually they use music as a way to
put them in a reason to remember it's
like the glue you know between these
these small chunks and they use this
whole thing as a recipe to build
equivalences that on at the other at the
other end so these to me are people who
are more at the end of being coming up
with creative solutions that are clever
in the sense that they they are not
based on on this rational thinking on
this power of computation but in the
ability to establish dance really with
with the materials and to use so
so-called you know sensory motor
abilities to help the world to have half
of the work for you I think I should
finish soon the future of play when
playing education I pass very quickly
the problem with playing education I
call it when the solution becomes the
problem I call it don't kill the play by
adding the learning they they are many
see play by definition cannot be
commodified and this is the difficulty
so there is much talk especially these
days about measurable gains academic and
professional associated with play and
learning the problem is to me that the
slow infusion of ever stronger doses of
seriousness into play can actually at
once kill the play and hamper the
learning in other words ddd the examples
of can't play are common in the field of
education and also of entertainment you
know it's horrible when you when you
talk with educators who want to
to deliver in more playful ways the
contents of the particular curriculum
and you receive these boxes it's like
cornflakes you know give it to your kids
and they will become smart and it has
actually led to scandals with with with
Mozart finally people became tired of
this rhetoric of selling toys also and I
mean I don't have to go in detail more
about that the future of place the idea
that today's children don't always play
learn or mingle the way we expect them
to end what if they did it in richer
ways that we don't always see there are
a few areas of change that are very
clear even if one doesn't want to
exaggerate the generational gaps
it's that today's children are
developing new ways of relating because
their neighborhoods their community as
we know them are no longer the same so
they invent other ways to keep
relational bonds beyond borders they're
their identities are also shifting
because in a way between private and
public you know
the boundaries are changing also
different ways of moving between places
and what you consider home there are
many children who want if they have
split families they want either to have
the same toys in both homes or they
carry like little ninja turtle bags that
are always heavier because they actually
want to carry the thing with them and
and and and what they want is they
become fascinated with all the older
plate allows them to actually glide
between these these places one important
difference is also the relationship to
literacy because with the tools that we
have now even if you think of writing
what you have you don't have this
separation between writing and reading
anymore like it takes you an evening to
read the book and failure to write it no
it's like they meet in between in what I
call a notation because the reading
becomes more and more active because you
can cut and paste you can highlight you
can reiterate whatever you borrow and
read and you can also when you are on
the right-hand side you take these
chunks and you sort of pass them on more
quick quicker so you have this
circulation and distribution of
half-baked ideas that is very
characteristic of the way in which the
kids work and that create incredible
problems in education but the point that
I want to make is that all this is true
but maybe one of the most interesting
things is that the children today are
reclaiming their body and reclaiming a
sense of place they have it's as if they
had been in in in in the individual word
for for a bit long so now you have the
emergence of all these toys like we but
you had you have also the children who
actually begin to reinsure
even if they go on the web they pay more
attention to the context the physical
context in which they do that so I I
have one slide here that is sort of the
manifest of the digital kid you know
what they were they would like from it
says give me throws that I can carry
along give me toys that make me feel
home wherever I am
give me toys that help me find my ways
and orient myself so this is besides the
leaping and you know that allow me to to
give me building elements that I won't
lose this is difficult if you are if you
are a builder on the go it's like Lego
won't work because you know you lose
them
and and to capture this notion is like
maybe able to make me able to explore
and use my creative skills locally
globally anywhere anytime but please
don't forget I do have a body and I like
to use it I'm exuberant I am physical so
make me fly transport me and teleport me
but also make me touch feel move ground
me I think I have to stop I am going to
pass because I had of course a whole
part on how you design environments for
people to actually be able to engage in
play in place one important
characteristic is that it's good if
environments or artifacts have holding
power this is the notion that they don't
just say use you Wow and then you get
tired of them but you can revisit them
constantly and and it's a and and it's
actually growing reaiiy grow with my
toys and my toys grow with me is the
idea here there are other qualities of
these environments that are important
that they allow you to immerse yourself
but then to come back that they are
forgiving in the sense that nothing
kills it that's what's so useful in
video games you can change perspective
you can change the scale of things you
become a giant and then you become a
little ant you can change your stance in
the world the notion that these spaces
have always to be comfortable in a way
they are often called third places they
are neither like home nor like work they
are more like stages or cafes or places
where you know when you come in that you
can behave differently it's like if I go
to a bar I know I put my red lipstick
and so on because because it's a third
place and and I can stretch and explore
aspects of myself that I don't do if I
am in a profession of me
you know with some corporate people or
something like this
another important thing and I'm so happy
I heard about is here it's no
segregation by age I had the chance to
work for three years in a European
project which had the ugly title of
intergenerational learning but it's key
it's so important and that's what I like
about museums because I am a
developmental psychologist I am always
asked when I work mostly with educators
like is this developmentally correct is
this the exact target group for this
activity and I'm going I am trying to do
that well it's like when you are an
architect it has to function but then
something else have to happen so yes
they have to be targeted but guess what
they have to transcend and in order to
transcend they have to please people
from different backgrounds walk of life
experience age and they have to have an
integrity that actually engages people
from different walks of life so in a way
it's to think about places in which
people that otherwise wouldn't meet come
together to do things that they
otherwise wouldn't do so that's a nice
definition of the types of of a third of
third places last slide I if you think
about the almost like the different my
phases in a learning or in a play
process so sometimes we call it the five
C's it's like you have to connect you
have to be inspired it's a WoW moment
you psych up and then to think about the
type of space but not as in a physical
space you know that is dedicated but the
kind of mental space that you need in
order to be inspired to connect and so
on I called it the Imaginarium if you
are in immersing yourself hands on but
also body immersion if you build if you
try out things
the idea is more like the Exploratorium
if you if you if you think about things
contemplate reflect it's sometimes they
call it heads in which is bit an ugly
term it's more like the sanctuary
because you want you you want in in a
way some quiet in order to play back and
that's what I spoke the whole evening
it's that category to play back things
to revisit to recast to give them form
to ideas to dramatize it's the stage and
and and share negotiate collaborate
mingle it's the Piazza so these are
again there they are
voila I am done thank you I think I
think nothing is harder than to give
recommendations that are specific enough
for people who want to design
environments that are rich for play and
learning so I am only scratching the
surface because the recommendations are
much too general and even if you start
really defining the qualities of these
environments like they have to allow
iteration they have to be forgiving they
have to be like good enough mother's
they have to be these they have to be
that it's always a little bit too
general and it doesn't quite it doesn't
quite help but we I leave this for the
discussion thank you
well thank you very much we have a four
year old granddaughter and she likes to
play hide and seek
and I was wondering yes what's the yes
what's the attraction or the interest or
the cure what is what is it about
hide-and-seek
thank you for this question it starts in
baby hood with peekaboo
it takes various form it hide-and-seek
is one form it all has to do with
enactments that the children enjoy and
in which they play a very active role to
engage in to actually explore this
notion of permanency object permanency
and object when when when we talk about
object permanency we don't think just of
objects but of people and it starts with
very young children who love these games
of I am here I'm not here I'm here I'm
not here the little devil that comes out
of the box
oops it comes up it goes back it
disappears it comes back because young
children don't have permanency of object
object permanency so when a ball
disappears behind the sofa it's gone no
problem no attachment happy I'm said
used by the next thing that come my way
but around the age of eight months they
begin to be shy of strangers precisely
because there is a memory of something
that has gone it starts to develop in
and all the games of I think
hide-and-seek and so on there there are
different versions for people of
different ages to play out like as in
theater these coming and going of things
it's it's it's again it's like
the absence and the presence the leap
and I come back and the hide-and-seek is
a little bit particular because little
kids don't understand when they don't
understand what they need to do to be
really hidden from somebody else so it's
another very interesting thing that gets
enacted there it's it's about learning
to take on perspectives to understand
almost like what's in the mind of
somebody else who are not who is not in
your position you see and and it's one
way of actually enacting these kinds of
puzzlement about but when they are
little they don't get it I mean I don't
know your your four-year-old way how
they play hide-and-seek but okay that's
pretty good and but you see this can
it's hard to interpret too much but this
can all almost be an enactment of I made
this up of I know you're gonna find me
again
because there is always this double joy
pleasure and puzzlement about I want to
go I want to be autonomous
I want separation I want to be releases
I want to be the traveler I want not to
be attached but at the same time I want
to be attached I want to be Penelope I
want to come back I want to be comfort
and these are very difficult balances to
achieve and it's it's it's at its it's
at the heart and core of what it means
to to grow as a person as well you know
at a personal level as well as in as a
sort of cognitive level or relation or
relational level these are these are
almost archetypes
and I think that in the in the types of
obsessions or archetypes that that the
digital natives people today engage in
have even more to do with that because
they are sometimes unwillingly living
lives where they constantly move between
worlds they are more they they are more
like nomads and what do the nomads do
they always come back they have these
rituals of come back so you have many
many examples in a way of kids the way I
imagine these mythologies is again about
I am going you don't know where I am but
I am having fun and I am capturing
things in the environment you can be
with your cell phone it's like
photographing what you eat you know I am
going but I keep track I keep trace I
give them I it's not even leaving a mark
this but I keep track and then you know
at night what do I do I contact my
friends to show them what I have been
doing because that is as important so in
a way you can you can all of the sudden
shed light on some even of the of the
technologies that they like to carry
around or the things that they like to
do through this lens because you begin
to realize that they love to share their
captures they save them for later and
then they love to share them on a common
even if it's online it's it allows them
to play these games of I go I come back
it's a long answer to hide-and-seek
could you comment on your you were
speaking about all the elements you know
in a public space of inspiring kids to
be hands-on and to immerse themselves
but now we have a society and a lot of
public spaces where everybody has hand
sanitizer and they don't want yes they
don't want kids to touch anything I work
in a hospital so yeah that challenge of
inspired get the kids to move be a part
of something but don't touch it really
because we can you can come I have no
good answer I only have hopes that I see
symptoms of new new rituals around
around that we see that go counter this
tendency and the example I have in mind
is the makers faire it's a very strange
phenomenon where all of the sudden you
have all these people who have lived
online you know who have created their
own second lives and all these things
they come together like to go to
Woodstock you know in tribes and what do
they do they build stuff and they show
it to one another and and it has to be
in a physical place and some people like
it some people don't some people think
it's not really art it's not innovative
it's not but I cannot answer your
question I can just try to become
attentive while is this this trend is
certainly very strong of creative ways
in which especially younger people but
not only you know in which younger
people actually deal with these kinds of
challenges and one of them was also that
there was an incredible resilience
that's a certain point on the part of
the geeks the ones who live constantly
in the virtual world to actually
establish rapport with other people that
are not physical it's it's they were
very close but it was not necessarily
physically close and I don't know what
these does on on on on on on the other
hand you have these ways in which people
come together also in hybrid ways that
are very interesting you know it's not
only in online or or or and I become
myself more and more interested in all
in studying not just when when you you
look at kids or young people staring at
a computer screen and entering in their
world it's interesting to look at how
they actually go in each other's houses
there are lots of rituals around this
that go beyond just what they stare at
they like to slouch on couches they have
their own way of keeping a physical
hopper who is the place and other people
even if they they they go away every now
and then it's like when we have our cell
phones we are still here and and I think
the only way to go about this is to
study these hybrids where this physical
virtual and digital merging sort of
interesting and unusual ways that's all
I can say it's very difficult to but I
agree you know I arrived yesterday
monopolies in at 3 o clock and I am in
the the center of the city the the
financial center I guess my question is
like don't disparage empty where are
people here
it's like you have these treats that are
totally empty you have these gorgeous
huge buildings the windows of which you
cannot open most of the time and it is a
striking shock when you arrive and but I
am an optimist because I think that
people are very smart at inventing for
themselves places and environments and
rituals that make for that and you know
if you take I come from Europe and I was
like an intellectual in the 60s and the
cafe was sacred and so on but I enjoy
when I see all the geeks working on
their own computer in the cyber cafe
it's not the same but it's it's a funny
way that they have to come together
without talking to one another in pencil
it's like you know it's maybe now they
start doing things together they
communicate a lot through what they are
doing which is also can lead to to to to
stew some you know and indeed jump you
know the the what what is also very nice
is that there is no at the Exploratorium
I don't know if you were there kids at
the Exploratorium the organ did they
they did the whole activity around sound
you yes and there was actually one
session were very known artists sound
artists came to talk about their work
and it was very nice to see the kinds of
questions from the young the young
makers the quest they had no sense of
hierarchy they had no sense of comparing
their production with the production of
you know Walter key too
or other wonderful artists work we found
the questions were all technical how do
you get this you know sound to come out
from these dudes the questions were all
technical and I found this very
interesting because it's it's again it's
as if they were in this world of
hobbyists of makers that work together
and the question is how to optimize what
I am really interested in in doing so
they they are very refreshing in the
questions they ask because it's not like
the usual shy shyness you know in in
front of the big artists I don't know
what what it entails in terms of the
quality of their work with you know it's
not enough to just throw out something
in the indie and then it's enough and
when we I have organized workshops for
kids designer kids play kids technology
more than you ever want to participate
in anymore
and usually they stop when every kid
come with a little contraption that they
have built it's more or less cute or not
you can say yeah it's great
but you never have the time to come back
and then actually either really respect
the work by rechoreograph in different
ways or imagining games like the
children come back with what they have
produced and you go for a second round
saying for example take whatever
inspires you best even if it's not your
own and continue to work on it as if it
were your own
and you go through iterations and there
has to be way to allow these productions
to become better crafted to become more
polished and also to become something
that is bigger than just my own little
first attempt that you know sketching
something and the
is very important but it's easier said
than done I have a question for you now
we've been talking about or you've been
talking about the so the internal
technical inside space of lifestyles of
children in this country but we're
becoming more urbanized what do you
perceive our changes that are taking
place and how families raise their
children and more urban environments
versus say forty years ago when it was
more suburban and rural yes that's a
whole other very complicated question is
that I like to almost start from the
point of view of the child thinking sort
of what's in their mind what's on their
plate and what's in their toy chests you
know and from the point of view of the
child often time they have single
parents or they have split family
situations they also have situations
where parents get remarried after having
had children so there are many kids
around like it's this tribe of kids so I
always like to think that the kid is
sinking I love to go out with my family
but can you tell me who is part of my
family and and you know where they have
they have their own way of because it's
not so clear sometimes they have their
own way of reinventing the the family in
terms of the kinds of people that they
want around themselves to feel good and
and those are all the examples we worked
a lot on this one at lego to try to
understand how they respond to these
situations precisely for example if you
have you know you live
one apartment in town at some point in
another the kids like either they are
very different they either they like to
have duplicates to to feel at home or
almost anywhere which is not really home
it's it's like it's like in America when
you travel I think Americans are a
nomadic tribe without them realizing it
because they came to this country and
they they were more pioneers so this
nice thing of high quality it's not just
a mobile home it's the it's the the
thing that you find wherever you go it
can be the Macdonald it can go when you
go to a park it's that particular bench
so when people come in a way it is the
same because it's a duplicate of it so
if a child travels with their parent and
each time when you stop you find those
benches and it's okay and you eat your
McDonald you eat it's okay it's a it's
not too disturbing so that's for the
part of being comforted in India in its
the notion of the carpet that the
nomadic people carry with them and that
is the most precious object because
wherever they go they stake their
territory they stiffen your home and
there are all these nice studies that
are done also by artists about how
people inhabit spaces that they know
they cannot stay long in like hotels or
how how they relate to their luggage you
know to their objects in luggage and
again there are very different
strategies there there are those who no
matter where they are in the hotel how
horrible or beautiful they always have
to put a few objects in very particular
place to stake their territory and feel
at home and otherwise they don't others
don't care they put themselves in a
bubble the only thing they want is the
place
to put on their computer because that's
home that's why I go through my email I
am comforted and the shower should be
good and the bed should be good but they
don't they don't they disdain a bubble
and that's what they bring with with
themselves and the children do that a
lot so for example in the world of toys
I worked for Lego for so and the
beginning was all about bricks but you
can't carry bricks along so if you have
different places where you go to you
just need your stack of bricks if you if
children travel what they like is to
bring little micro worlds with
themselves the mini wood little mini
words where you can do things or all the
video games because they come with you
you know I I understand that they that
they like to bring their little I like
to bring my computer with me now when I
travel because it's again it's a way of
settling
it's about settling even if if you know
that the places in which you settle are
totally in not permanent and in fragile
you talked about perspective in play can
you talk a little bit about especially
for the digital natives about watching
themselves watching themselves play that
phenomena of them being on camera or
them seeing themselves can you say a bit
more what they do well it came mostly
from another generation of the MTV
generation where they watch themselves
dance or do things and they their
behavior changed now with some of these
digital natives with virtual cam webcam
they're watching themselves behave in a
way and they're changing at Skype
they're watching themselves change how
they play yeah this is what this is
wonderful because
it is almost a technique to allow to
modify as you go along the narrative and
also the way in which you want to
portray yourself because it keeps track
of what you are doing in a way that you
cannot appreciate if you are really in
the action so it's it's it's a way of
actually having these mirrors mirrors
are have been important like in the
Reggio Emilia school system for young
children they use mirrors a lot and and
and all kinds of mirrors they have for
example these triangular mirrors where
people go in they have all kinds of meal
of mirrors and maybe it's a way to I
don't know to be to to keep track and to
be able to to operate these desire
changes in in their in in their own
appearance identity to play around to
explore that I don't quite know what
strikes me also is the dhih dhih the all
these versions of karaoke I don't know
what this is about I am sure you have
better insights than I have on this why
do we like Legos so much my goodness
okay this has to do I think with I said
at some point that one quality of
environment can be I grow with my toys
my toys grow with me and they have they
are very constrained and I think they
have affordances that don't please
everybody so what they are good at is
that some people call it low floor high
ceiling
you enter you begin to use your hands
even if you have no ideas you believe
something and it gives you an idea and
then you you change it and it gives you
an idea so it's this notion that you
start by meddling around even if you
have no ideas and it's delightful to see
that as you go along you see things that
are surprising and it makes you have
better ideas and you go on and you and
you sharpen it it's not like to solve a
problem that has one definite solution
so that's one thing that I think we like
what we like is the modular quality of
the environment is that you you know
somehow that there are many different
ways of connecting things and that it
will always work because the system is
modular even if it's very constrained I
think also that the repertoire itself
has become rich enough that you can move
beyond it just building towers and
orthogonal structures you can start
doing other things like if you add
motors or sensors you can start you know
doing interesting thing what I think
Lego does not address is the the wide
walls aspect when people talk about low
floor high ceiling there is this notion
wide walls mean it attracts many
different types of people because it is
very layered and it is very rich in the
sense that it speaks to many people and
I think Lego in a way speaks to boys
it speaks to it wants to speak to boys
it doesn't mean that many girls are not
interested in but they have been working
along this path of just developing these
wonderful elements to build these
orthogonal structures but what you see
in workshops is that there are some
people who are more attracted
to using let's say even-even contraption
that does something like a robot or a
conveyor belt or some mechanical device
they come from a world in which they
light more I call it an organic rather
than mechanical metaphors that they live
by and they like to create little
creatures that will sense if there is no
more water in the in the earth for the
plant and that that will just you know
water the plant or some device that does
something in the environment but it's
not you control it or it controls
something else in very mechanical terms
so in a way Lego I think they have tried
they started they actually at some point
we are working on a very interesting
system it was it called I forgot the
name where you could do jewelry in this
modular ways and they had watches where
you could do them in in a modular way
snap it or some other work like this
snap it snap it together they were
wonderful they were like plexi wires and
you had these elements that you could
click on it so you could do colors you
could do earrings but you could also if
you are a boy a little boy you could do
accessories you could do daiquiri
decoration because you could attach them
on other objects in the environment they
had a wonderful quality but they never
made it because because the I think the
culture itself is still very growing
around the brick and you know it's the
brick
oh it was mentioned that you have had
some influence from Maria Montessori and
I'm just wondering if as a Montessori
and it's always interesting to hear what
parts people are attracted to and yeah I
can imagine certain things but I'm just
wondering if you could expound on that a
bit
yeah the there are two things that
Madame Montessori did very well I think
is it's this notion that if you actually
want to open space in the children's
minds their environment has to be pretty
well organized it's this paradox that a
space that for especially for little
children they have to know where the
materials are where they can find them
to actually help them understand that
they could use them if everything is
messy around if there is absolutely no
clarity in what could be found where it
makes it more difficult to be creative
it's it's a paradoxical idea and and
from my readings of the text of Maria
Montessori is that and this comes
through very much in the radio Amelia
schools infant toddler schools it is
very organized but not as in in a
military way in a very gentle way and
the children are invited to the rituals
of bringing the things back and then we
can play we open it up but we bring them
back so that everybody knows where
things are that's one thing and the
other one is just many of these
materials have the quality of the fröbel
gifts they are extraordinary embodiments
of aspects of a phenomenon that you can
play
but then again the danger is if somebody
who is not very knowledgeable about the
fact that if you want children to
understand a phenomenon you have to
various of those embodiments maybe can
become too rigid I don't know but for
example the Montessori bells you could
imagine very different ways in which you
can give a child a sense of music and
the Montessori bells are just a very
nice one possible embodiment of aspects
of the phenomenon then you can have
games where for example you play with
the synesthesia between movement and
sound you could have just playing an
instrument you could have building
rhythm machines I think the art and
probably she was very good at this I
don't know enough about Montessori
because it's not really from within I
have never really worked him in a
Montessori School but the art is really
to to imagine these different ways in
which you can unfold the phenomenon
because otherwise embodiments are not
good enough you see it makes me sad and
sick when I hear now there is this
incredible fad among academics
everything has to be embodied and bodied
cognition and body and it is nothing
else then I call it in my own academic
term it's a return of a certain kind of
empiricism it's like play with this
thing play with these these cakes and
you will understand fractions or you
know play with these materials because
the idea is that the concept is embodied
in the materials which is never the case
but I think I think that the Montessori
materials are especially the way they
are used in Montessori School do that
very well and and and the third thing I
like about her is that the senses are
important to her maybe more than to
Piaget because he was more interested in
the child as a young scientist and it
was more heady
so the materials that they came up with
this game like situation in which you
invite the kids to play
they are also kind of nice but not as
nice
you know they he doesn't pay attention
to the senses so much which mad madam
Montessori does I don't know if there
are still aspects that you think of that
I let let aside that you enjoy oh um
well it was interesting to hear you talk
about the child is the foreigner and she
had she had thought that it was
important for the child to have a heavy
dose of realism in in herb stages of
development the realism comes first in
the imagination later as a teacher I
always have trouble with talking with
parents about that they get very upset
about me pooh-poohing Winnie the Pooh
for instance at least the Disney version
anyway when in fact what with the
children in Montessori tradition what
the children are needing is you know
practical life skills or like you talked
about like the sensorial materials that
maria montessori created for her
environments that that's an important
difference between say something like
waldorf yeah yeah yes and and i think
that they solve it very well in if i
think of the schools of Reggio i almost
think Reggio Emilia they have this
incredible beautiful way of working with
very young children and you can almost
think of it as if Madame Montessori was
still there she would be not school with
many artists who work with children like
Bruno Minari or people who work on
children and poetry and you know it's
it's very rich and in a way it's true
they would say things like you know we
are what we eat and the children have to
be
in a way they they have this lovely
kitchen and and you see the kids there
they are not completely crazy you know
and and they have these spaces where
they actually play games like going to
the store where they do these things but
at the same time they also do this
completely different types of things
they crawl through mirrors they do
things like this but they also do these
installations the kids to installation
so for example they use the the overhead
projector to project things and and when
you see the children play it's the same
I think it's us adults we have two ways
of establishing distinction between
realities and fiction it was a constant
discussion at lego and it I think it's a
better way to think of of the fact that
every reality is an invented reality and
and sometimes you need to play out
things that are varied that seem very
mundane like it's nice to to do to do
the dishes when mom does the dishes but
sometimes it's also about something else
you know sometimes it's about
hide-and-seek because there are not just
these pragmatic things that make us who
we are it's also the fears that we have
to weigh we see ourselves you know the
way we relate to other people and they
are there are traditions and and
grouping play types are all about that
so my suggestion would be to try to
break this distinction the way we
usually do it it's really things that
are more realistic and things that are
more imaginary or even in kids drawing
it's the realistic phase actually in the
kids drawing comes later because when
they are little they
what the what they know what they
imagine and then and then it becomes
more realistic I don't know but I myself
find it useful to abandon these ekata
means because you have too many people
who say you know the kids from inner
city they cannot pretend they have for
them it has to be very pragmatic the
girls the girls are more like realistic
and but it's like I need lots of studies
of young children's pretense and the
fundamentals are less about that then
about how they engage with the clay so I
did notice something it's neither the
girls are controlling when they are in
the kitchen and the boys when it's
outside or or the girls play more
realistic or you know it's more about
for the girls he would find things like
this it's like the choreograph so they
are like a giant and they have this
little thing this one talks to this one
and this one talks to this one in weight
then they take on a god-sized view and
everybody always says the girls are more
immersed the boys call like blue so it's
like there but their body almost becomes
you know the airplane and so on so I
don't know if it's a boy-girl thing and
I would not want to have me quoted on it
but they are these different ways in
which people and and again it shifts
because the ones who at some moment are
the choreographers then they dwell in
because they project themselves in the
character they make it grow and then
they they speak from the point of view
of the character and no longer just like
you know organizing and it's very
difficult to talk about reality or
fiction in that way because in those
ways because sometimes I don't know
realities strangers of our fictions some